yeah hello welcome to this broadcast I
hope I'm life as usual there's this
nagging feeling there might be something
wrong but this is what I am asking every
time I'm sorry I need to do it if I'm
live give me a short message and the
chat would be great so let's get going
yeah someone tells me I'm life that's
cool so let's play some games yep five
minutes yes here was this llamo from
Turkey so let's see what I can do here
I'm going for a Sicilian we should be
two words not exactly looking very
ambitious ok that's fine shadow again so
somewhat slowish buildups that can be so
bad ok maybe go d5 c300 it plays d 3
that's not very ambitious let's grab the
center if he takes Queen d5 I don't mind
that he cannot attack my queen
yeah I would have liked to take with the
night admittedly but didn't work out but
dwell he's not detecting that Queen
anytime soon what he can try some
something okay maybe he's going for
night you for playing on the dark
squares 94 yeah maybe anyway there's a
question I'm going to be playing a 2200
player I'm 1800 any tips um yeah I've
got a tip just play whatever you would
play against an 1800 player as well yeah
just play a normal game it's not a
brilliant idea to do something totally
different if you fades a stronger
opponent at least try to be yourself
don't try to play something that you
don't that you don't know where that you
feel at home it's better to play
something that you did you know let's
say or some kind of game that you are
comfortable with and try something
entirely different soil is asking and
we're looking to write any more books in
the future um it was an interesting
experience um definitely to write that
book the only thing that is some pretty
clear it's not a very very sensible
economic decision to write a book you
simply don't earn um a decent amount of
money with it um it's in it's not like
ever it's not the fault of the publisher
or anything it's not like that it's just
that with with chess books you don't
earn lots of money it's a very bad let's
say I will you rate that you that you
can calculate for that
I'm still I would like to ride one but
I'm going to I have to think about it
what what under which circumstances and
and so on okay that that position here
is nice I've got a good central control
it's just that I'm not totally sure how
to build up from here that long diagonal
is nice but difficult to do something
with ya I wonder f5 grabbing more space
they'd also weakens quite a bit I can do
second with this maybe I had say had a
funny tactic in a game last year which
was kind of comparable this position on
before and d4 but it's not going to
happen here as well can i play something
like g500 so then he goes d4 that's
crazy ok let's centralized
can you recommend online against the chi
goran that would be the cheek or in
defense in the Queens gambit decline and
they not declined in the Queens gambit
um sure almost everything is good oops
wyd resigned why did he resign that is a
surprise now okay probably am there was
something happening like doorbell
ringing things like that it happened to
me more than once yeah pizza at the door
okay that's a question do I plan on
making any more opening uncovered
serious um yep I do chess openings are
covered as a series on my channel um
where I've got one opening under the
under the under the microscope that's
the right word not really it's not
really the microscope I'm giving an
overview of an opening i did this for
for the night or for the UM for the
names of indian yeah like here nibsy
with III and you just presented the main
possibilities to give an overview what
what happens yes I will do those kind of
videos it's some something like the
Benoni semi Slav would be really cool
yeah that would be two different videos
then right yeah maybe both are popular
openings but nobody is more popular on a
on a let's say I'm on a normal level the
semi slab is more of a pro opening it's
not not played that often in num num ya
normal level chest let's say yeah Bishop
g5 if you loved that pin surprisingly
enough okay well here with the night on
d7 it's not as terrible as it is in
other and other circumstances anyway
mmm it's a question do I plan to finish
my a 45 series in the future hmm yeah I
think I have to at at some point okay
Bishop a6 he wants to do something on
the sea porn maybe cover it for the
moment yay against the chi Goran um what
is good one one line that is pretty good
as to just play Knight way let's check
here ok let's go F for um d4 d5 see 496
Knight f3 Bishop g4 Knight c3 e6 CD 585
that's a pretty good line yeah and the
simple line ok so here I'm going to go
for broke rather quickly sacrificing the
exchange not sure if it is enough but it
is an interesting way to play so night
g3 immediately or do I go d5 first I
think that's hard to believe that black
can't afford to take on d4 twice with e
5 also then getting in the mix maybe
it's a bit of a gamble so yeah Queen f3
maybe to attack f6 to do this I mean
someone is some discussing what I'm
should post just wins or losses in my
channel yeah I've always be posting wins
and losses and the question maybe
challenge you today and it's totally not
meant to be but you can try the thing is
I have no idea in
that in that soft way and the Blitzen
software how to actually accept the
challenge I'm always my standard setting
is child that I'm not open for
challenges simply because I'm quite
often bid lead to it but they're doing
bit ly doing things OOP that's difficult
so I preferred to not be open for
challenges yeah h4 here is that
happening yeah I have to have to be
quick here yeah but it's probably not
such a great idea right I cannot really
take on f6 hmm now that wasn't a good
idea just should have just played 95
yeah opponent's name is for princesses a
bit of an unusual name but a h4 was
probably not very useful I wonder maybe
i can go h5 rook g5 king edge to
something like that and then grab that
pawn that that wouldn't be so out of the
out of this world night at five anyway i
can do that actually that's interesting
try and then aged 59 h6 that's quite
interesting next position is not so easy
to play the bishop on a sixth of doing
anything yeah you don't why am I not
sounding exciting when talking about
finishing that repertoire series um yeah
the thing is that there's little room
for me to discover myself if I'm doing
that I'm finishing that serious i'm
basically i'm presenting my own
repertoire and it's like watching the
same movie all over again yet at some
point it gets a bit boring so what now
let's do this maybe if he goes up to g5
i go here Knight f6 is hanging difficult
i'm not quite sure i think i have
compensation here night chief or is that
possible rook g8 maybe i can just take
it's also interesting i'm getting some
points there oh gee four and then taking
how is he covered actually he cannot
really cover it i'm not sure that might
be a bad idea is kabuki g8 and for Luke
h5 ok so let's stop here and now it's
got bishop CA okay then then that was a
bad idea I didn't see Bishop c8 coming
hmm a stupid stupid plane
and then i misplayed that i had very
nice compensation now I've got nothing
we should be too maybe I can get in
Bishop e2 and back back to everyone or
something like that hmm alright still
not completely easy fam that's nice 44 I
saw that you for idea mmm fruit you have
this e for check i terribly miss plated
it was a nice position really i think
okay i cannot capture with with anything
Wow
janet's probably losing somehow rook age
five the Queen f6 red narrow gauge fire
that's probably strong I can go checking
go King edge too but hmm yeah okay so
you're winning here how exactly I can
just take her that's it simple t6
anything not really now okay so let's
resign that there was a shame had a nice
compensation for that exchange but
didn't turn didn't them work out okay
let's go d 4 and there's a question have
i read the book the modern tiger and do
i consider writing a review of it yeah
it yeah it's a it's it's a good book of
course but there are so many books to
post reviews on i also have a couple on
that some some people sent to me to do
reviews on and I should do those first
um yeah i will post some book reviews
definitely but it's well it will take em
take a couple of weeks probably i don't
know i have no I have no very clear
concept when when to do it but term so
let's play it simple take here and go 25
you know why do I should be a little bit
better here take here
on jigs hmm it looks suspicious it
really does 94 fe 4
it doesn't seem to be a direct
refutation so let's go i form my where
can i see where i can you see my book
reviews here on my youtube channel so
okay let's get rid of that thing and
then go before there's a question have i
read Daniel Daniel King's book on the
night off yeah but it's a very odd book
right it's from the from the 90s or
something I think he's written more than
one so it could be that i'm not totally
up to date so why is he got his bishop
right into my position that's that's bad
news really
it's a bit weird allowing me to check v6
but okay yeah my Ruca some kind of
flexible there oh I didn't see that one
but it is it is not not as terrible so
here yeah if you are still interested in
shares after losing 200 games you have
the potential to become a good player
yeah sounds a like a quilt statement but
it's not very realistic 200 games in a
row is a bit much yeah it's a funny
situation and I don't really know both
sides have a hard time moving he's got
everything he has on that a for porn and
have it covered and if he moves the
queen or look away i'm taking b5 and i'm
better but i can also do i also have big
issues to move anything that's not
really working there I was thinking if
there's some kind of tactic I actually
had an idea he had an idea of bringing
it in to see to of all places so I can
go who can I go to d 6 p-6 that's not
working
okay let's see if I can get some counter
play him
what is he doing actually I can go f5 f6
for example taking with the bishop or
what way exactly even look symbolism
move it's a strange game in any case a
little bit if you care very much about
losing games and chess is difficult to
play I mean you should always care if
you lose that set through what you will
always lose games no matter how good you
are so if a chick g5 here Queen B 5
Queen f7 just about works at whole play
of black is kind of strange anyway
that was the idea Wow
hd5 is hanging so okay I have to take on
d5 and hope that somehow this is sister
something okay here this food is the sky
it's a relatively new account okay
that the whole way that game was played
but ok I am won't say it I won't say it
yeah okay I'm resigning him and I'm
going to check that game later
definitely um anyway let's go for I go
for a new game I unsure i was a bit of a
bit of a strange game i don't know i'm
i'm kind of um yeah recently a number of
cheetahs has increased online really a
lot papua 29 so let's see what happens
here kingsland year now ok so is playing
the this line ok the mckagan off
variation currently pretty much in
fashion ok
let's see play normal normal stuff yeah
I'm used to to having this position from
the white side so seeing it from black
is a bit a bit uncommon let's see if I
can open the C file for some counter
play here how do i play this position
with black he just canceled short it's
not so frequently seen often why this
kind of flexible and tries to play form
for long canceling okay I'm trying to
play for b5 here if I go or now thats
good here right probably first this move
let's see for I can still play be 5 mm
yeah and let's play b5 here I need to
get something going so you take it and
nighty for I guess or to a 69 96 looks
strange so let's go to a form that's the
more active move
yeah I can take that couple of times if
i can get my bishop activated that f8
bishop I'm okay currently I'm not seeing
how how to do that Bishop over to be six
would be would be need of course but not
easy to get hmm push up to h6 of course
it's also something that would help and
this is some porn damn the b5 porn
sometimes a liability I'm doing this
preventing any F for ideas and now
Bishop over to be six it slow it really
is but I hope it works one one
disadvantage of putting the lateral yet
is that pressure only for has been
reduced as we see him so yeah I can
still do that I think Knight a5 I could
have taken so okay Allah is offering
that trade and now Bishop is six ok
yeah I today announced that my channel
is doing a little bit of a change the
daily program let's say is now
consisting of one blitz game and an
additional longer video some
instructional content lesser blitz games
yeah i'm going to try that I don't see
how it how it works out um currently I
want to focus more on that instructional
content and play less blitz so I think
it's um it's an interesting interesting
change that's an interesting move if I
take on g4 he might take it huh what a
weird idea but interesting definitely
interesting
f5 you can take twice unfortunately can
i play f5 EF Knight f6 that looks very
nice it's not working probably not
working ship chief for that was an
interesting move really that's also not
good wow okay I have to take this I
guess and now you place that and now an
idea six is just okay of course while
completely misunderstanding here what
okay maybe you can go Quincy sexier
maybe you can but I don't know yeah okay
I'm going to do this I'm not totally
sure about it but should be okay my
night only six is pretty good pretty
good bloke Ada and very nicely
controlling all the squares maybe I get
in ok prevented that so over here I know
94 bitten better not let's not allow
night before so easily yeah I'm a porn
up after all those adventures
night c4 maybe let's do this as a check
as well then bring the King up
so back back I guess you lose using all
the pawns okay I need to cover be five
it's no way i can give up that one that
step looks like a winning end gammas
someone on the John the chat says yeah
viewer review games i will do more i
will do more i just today finish them
analysis on one I just have to record
the video I had a couple of questions
about that game wasn't quite sure about
some circumstances okay so this will
mostly be a time issue twenty-something
seconds is tricky
okay III chick should be should be
strong for f2f1 queens give me a queen
we all need Queens and that's made okay
that was a win whoo ok and so let me
check am I going to participate in the
stream a tournament on chess.com yes yes
I am where's the button yep new new game
that's a question can you explain why in
your boggle repertoire went to put the
night on g7 and when to c6 I can't see a
logic there mmm let me think about that
yes there's a logic in that repertoire
um I hope so there are normally you play
night bg7 and d5 in the in the main line
with Bishop t2 there are and there are
cases where 96 displayed after night BTW
too that's a question what about the
rapid videos on my new channel yeah the
rapid videos would be em like that daily
additional video like one blitz and one
rapid that will happen quite frequently
I'd like to play the 2510 that's it's a
good it's a good time control so
whatever this has t hoff something and
he's playing the super sharp coral
variation and now he plays g4
that is boring white why are you playing
boring stuff and the worst part is not
so bad even let's go here okay Jade I
don't really know it that well that line
wow thats it seems slow really a bit
slow queen bee three
okay i don't know maybe you can maybe i
can do it like that just very simple and
now trying to sacrifice on g4 it's a
yeah hmm as usual it's the Kings engines
kind of dicey night if to maybe as it's
a simple and good move no he's ambitious
so he tries to take on d6 properly with
justification mmm head hangs with a
check that's really the problem it's a
check dark okay
okay i have to have to do something
drastic normal measures won't be enough
with that probably is not working but
anyway at least it will irritate him I
hope maybe you can just take be seven or
something like that okay I broke p8 down
okay I'm grabbing this now threatening
93 Andrew cage too isn't that dangerous
okay can go to f2 you can just go to F
tune okay it's it's it's not it's not
super clear i can go look aged form and
age one hangs and yeah I don't know at
least I can arrest the hell out of him
typical Kings Indian bogus has probably
lost somehow but it's it's it's
irritating he'd he just took it okay but
because he wants to take b7 I see but
what what happens here he takes be so
look on the second and then f3 or
something how does he play then let's do
it
King even f3s night xe5 unfortunately
that's a bit of a shame otherwise f3
would be quite interesting my teefs I've
of all news then you will take on f3
would like to get my bishop somehow in
this in this game I don't see how long
now again I cannot take i was there
after between d phi is going to see to
so what does that mean actually is
attacking b7 still okay i'm down
everything but it's it's still kind of
interesting a little bit so you can give
a check there I after f3 will probably
just sacrifice that night okay I have no
square I have no square for that bloody
Queen I have to go to be six now that's
bad that's bad okay who I was a fun game
um jam unfortunately he will win that
yeah ok let's resign that I don't know
it was interesting i think it was
interesting probably not to correct but
ok so let's see what happens here
so gotta God Greenfeld mmm no I never
played Thomas ran law I think and I
don't know it sure I'm sorry I think he
does he does something for Chester calm
but i don't i don't really know the show
I'm sorry I how does that work
I've gotten the the whole thing I think
blacks line Lex Lyonya is not working at
all but i have i've totally forgotten
why so let's see here i can go Queen d2
as well I think however big cakes is
okay I mean Bishop takes King f1 can
cannot be really grateful black would be
quite surprising if it would be okay so
what about this mm-hmm just queen bee
three let's do that and then develop so
no before you ask I never watched Eric
Hanson play I know it's good but it's a
good player but I never watched his his
streams so what is this guy doing here
to me irritating me a lot Bishop a 6 I
can still go queen bee three right yeah
sometimes I problem with those people
play like instantly every move instantly
and super sharp stuff I never understand
how they can play like that yeah this is
the stuff that looks like its total
bonkers and maybe it's not yet but they
seem to figure it out in in many seconds
yeah or they just don't give a damn
thats then these are the two m2m things
probably the don't give a damn pod is
more important here I'm just two pawns
up I think you cannot play rugby 8 i've
got a mission 1 F for guy should be
should be really good for white skip the
pawn he was just firing the typical
drunken machine gunner style
yeah now he's thinking to two pawns down
and they have some possibilities maybe
to get to see six with my night the
other good idea would be something like
c4e form this should be three push push
pawns but c-4 would give him night
before which I'm not sure I want them to
have hmm my it's pretty it's pretty
awkward for black I don't see a decent
continuation might be eight doesn't look
right how high am i rated in the rapid
pool um I don't know I just I just
considered one draw in the twenty five
ten no twenty five ten fifteen that this
is this is what I could consider the
rapid poor now um yeah I have to check
at this guy's not playing is he
disconnected or something no pinging is
fine someone is requesting can I do one
round of sync field club sinquefield cup
live stream I will do 111 live broadcast
for the ICC actually I'm very much
looking forward to that together with
grandma's the last bow Henson from
Denmark would be a great event I really
like to play em airplay to do commentary
with a meme it was great fun to do this
earlier in the year um and doing a full
stream on my my own twitch of the the
event I'm not sure that I can get that
in would be interesting would be
interesting but i'm not sure if i can
get it in I have to work sometimes and
yeah I'm sorry guys this guy is just
letting the clock run down maybe a pizza
pizza guy at the door do I still have
some no cold coffee left yeah that's a
bit of a shame but ok the position is
very nice but would have liked to play
that on who do I think will win the sing
for cup now that's easy that's always
Magnus Carlsen even though we had a bet
Norway chess he's still the huge
favorite to win that event okay um nah
come on give me give me the wind before
fading okay now it no it did okay next
game Timo funny car who the heck is that
yeah the c3 is saying I haven't studied
that for ages now that I'm thinking of
picking up the Sicilian again I really
need you yes stuff like that can be
highly irritating so probably stay solid
at least the night on a three and Soviet
position in that I QP ok so I cannot
take why not okay show me maybe I cannot
take but takes King takes maybe maybe I
should have considered that we consider
that it can be risky check on the one
Bishop d7 95 this kind of business Wow
timmo phonica gem scan of what kind of
account is that come on guys you are
1600 in one minute and 23 40 in five
minutes hmm really nineteen hundred and
three minutes what is this nonsense is
there anybody not cheating here I come
on guys this is crazy okay but okay took
ages for Bishop f4 that actually points
at him not being a cheater but it's
still highly irritating and it's a good
move it's a good move of course yeah you
can just threaten their on 27 hmm
Wow hmm I totally did not see this
coming
I was just there was a move without
thinking I'd kept you on c3 I could have
played any any move and have some kind
of position where this is now I'm just
just lost it just lost I came let's
let's take them you can just spray look
be one I still have nothing I cannot do
nothing against 97
right h5 maybe I know it such a system
probably not matter doesn't matter much
probably hmm maybe what kind of a wacky
position is that ok so is taking this
here and then takes the look in the
corner I guess I'm taking here now is
unfortunately directly threatening again
otherwise this might might be somewhat
interesting I can get that a eight night
but it's probably not happening
what a what a weird game we should be
five and by the way it's very likely not
cheating it's just that those kind of
huge rating gaps that they're very often
suggest foul play but the game does not
really not so if we take this can I
somehow get stuff developed oh yeah look
to see some is good
oh yeah tough game Bishop d7 Roxy 7 it's
really really really tough he played
that very well I guess you can play 97
and b7 maybe head looks strong
I know I would start to get that night
yeah I know he does get that night back
into this game who gave 8i rook c8 I
mean I ass got 95 yeah you can play 95
and take no he cannot but this is still
strong okay guy played that well wow wow
it was good ah so let's see can I get a
win against our penguin here
okay it's going for some hybrid between
Slav and Greenfeld yeah my boots is
really rusty I think one reason is that
in recent weeks like two weeks I've been
numb I've been very busy and what I did
is I what I stopped doing is I'm kind of
I'm reorganizing my my my household if
you want you said a word household yeah
I think it is I'm um I'm setting stuff
that I don't need any more than typical
clutter that kind of you you a mess over
the years and i'm selling all kinds of
stuff yeah daily going to the post
office and so on it's interesting i also
saw with tons of chess books efore 95
mmm so let's go here yeah we'll chess
books that you really don't know I'd
really don't need don't know it's weird
so I'm going where do I go probably here
you're currently is Bishop is not doing
that much there's a question can can you
sell me something crazier what what do
what do you want I'm currently have lots
of stuff on eBay I've got only today I
sold some stuff and wood rice cooker I
sold them i sold my mom's old TV set
cool stuff and yes what is he going for
Queenie two or something yeah maybe this
is a good movie I've trying to do
something my ebay account is also chess
explained yeah you can go on ebay and
check chess explain find some stuff that
I'm selling
c5 ok
he can go Bishop de for which is very
very annoying idea hmm
gee I don't really see how to stop that
to be honest it's a bitter bit of a
problem now it's not that I'm
significantly worse or anything but I'm
not so sure how to play against that may
be Queen d2 to f4 someone says nigel
short is the worst commentator ever i
disagree i think nigel is one of the
best commentators you've got a really
excellent chess inside so i really think
he's got one of them he's one of the
best really why wouldn't you like him I
mean maybe you don't like him like his
sermon has some his personality that
that's it's that said something I would
understand but purely chess wise he's
pretty okay
okay what is happening here you really
go f5 no year maybe he does people have
no fear they have no fear nowadays it's
probably probably if the writings I
cannot go f3 that's the worst part yeah
you five Quincy 70 nothing nothing works
out here really mmm what a shame okay
see that someone is making fun of my
ebay sales yeah i'm selling some of
those crystal miniature figures from a
mother guys nothing to make fun of and
they're not mine so let's see here is
going to do something on f2
they played well that guy what can you
do I'd I'm not playing well but he's to
his stirring that is playing really good
chassis I think Queen g4 thats Queen
Queen f5 and I really have no great
reply to that amazingly do a read
paddock pedagogical stuff for my job as
a trainer no not really I think I should
but I mostly teach teach adults so I
really don't need stuff with kids let's
say but um yeah okay of course adults
some time teaching techniques are
helpful there as well but it's I think
more helpful for kids to know something
there yeah what a rotten position
it is not great ya can't blame um I
currently am there's some discussion in
the chat about chess commentators yeah I
think I really most most of them do a
pretty good job it's really that's
really am I think three the case they
all have them pluses and minuses someone
says Peter lake o is the it's the worst
chest commentator that's not true really
not um peter is an exceptionally good
player really and he's a very good
commentator he is just he doesn't have a
very exciting voice yes lon nua saying
um he's got excellent inside I mean I
met this guy you know and and he's
exceptionally nice that's the first
thing and I mean this guy can tell you
stories he went swimming here in
Budapest with Bobby Fischer can tell can
tell stories like that IAM that was just
fantastic stuff he met Bobby Fischer had
mcdonalds in Budapest and Fisher said he
feared that some mcdonalds staff would
be from the CIA that's really great
stuff all from PETA and he's a great guy
so don't don't say anything bad about
Peter lake oh I mean this is it I
understand his chances sometimes not so
exciting but he absolutely knows stuff
yeah okay so group g7 asks a bit of a
bit of a weird way to play it so let's
see here
he still has a good position I and I
don't believe it I don't believe it but
probably I'm just about in time and he's
got Queenie too I don't give me that so
do I draw at least this nonsense yeah I
do oh wow okay so one more games so yeah
it's fun to talk about the just
commentators yeah I think really a lot
of them are great someone mentioned Rena
crush I think she or she also is pretty
good I think she was pretty okay and
when what was that did you brought our
thing she did commentary on I think she
did a good job there was a good team
together with salmon Williams she am
yeah she did the positional stuff the
strategic stuff while Simon was dashing
out incorrect lines that was cool stuff
not so making fun I really like Simon
has a player and he's very entertaining
but sometimes sometimes it's pretty
funny what you suggest okay so let's
let's see um and I should know stuff
that's my book right
I have to pay a 97 bag I should have
played 97 immediately actually anyway it
should should be okay yeah someone
mentioned someone mentioned we are so
ceremony I think he's a excellent
commentator but i think what flora said
is a bit bit true sometimes it feels
like he addresses the audience like
there were little kids and this is a bit
strange given that most of the audience
won't be kids so what is this he's
allowing this listen look here right I
know Bishop f4 but I can't even take c3
then wow so we for nye def 694 or what
can I do something more drastic I that
really looks like it shouldn't work at
all ok let's do it
so here and then see thank you bishop
FYI will take c 3 i mean i just take
that pawn my ideas naija for coming now
you know I think I'm nobody mentioned
alejandro ramirez as a commentator I
think he's excellent not not mentioned
but his I think very good very good
inside and was really good stuff my
thoughts on my camera I think I buy a
dress that last week i mean i'm not
quite sure um what he should do but he
definitely should shouldn't be in front
of kids and talking about about chess
it's not a good idea and it also not in
front of adults maybe not in front of
anybody okay my ideas just to invade
with the Queen I don't see what he does
against it and i already have picked up
a pawn yeah I asus yeses voice and
mannerisms say I understand what you
mean isn't these are really nice he's a
really nice person if I also met him
playing in the Dutch league and he's
exceptionally friendly and very very
nice person but but yeah understand why
people wouldn't like that at some at
some point
yeah I'm not winning that game i really
i really don't know what say
yeah what is mr. arch was doing no
waiting
so let's check the let's not blunder
stuff Nyjah for probably even Mike comma
would win from that position always
giving a couple of dangerous checks here
I shouldn't go to age five that would be
a bad idea that would be a really bad
idea but I can do this huh
so let me check any other questions
where I already had over time so I'm
looking at a couple of questions um did
you read gamba boring book that's
winning paw structures I guess um I read
is a bit much i have that i use it
sometimes someone says he's not thinking
Magnus cards will be world champion for
too long considering the young GM's
coming up hmm well who's who's that
great why ye I don't know it depends i
think carlton has every chance to stay
world champion for quite a while it will
depend of course on the format if the
cousin suggested this kind of knockout
thing um and then it's a totally
different story anyway if this kind of
thing would be would be done um now I
don't have more than one copy of the
burren book I definitely I keep at all
books with instructional content anyway
I mostly sold old opening books was a
like em three to four hundred-odd
opening books and info Jason Foreman's
and stuff like that mm yeah the camera
is also potentials champs someone says
um he definitely has improved a lot yeah
but still winning the odd game against
cars would help um yeah this doesn't
mention our jump play Vincent Kaiba
that's a very young German play i think
is 11 years old now and very strong is a
good freedom master strength this is the
there are only really exceptional talent
out of Germany for ages which freed of
bread is the president would you have
preferred current or Kasparov yeah
that's a easy question who wants your
shimoff you have to be crazy to 22 want
him I mean
uh you could probably I mean I don't
know I have no idea yeah maybe I know
who would be worse than him she move and
this has got money if you had to play
the dragon on idol of what would she go
with night off and then both them in
both I'm probably getting checkmated do
you buy every opening book that comes
out no a lot lots of the three of
hundred were like a un chess stuff and
chess informed and some web I bought
quite a quite a quite a bit really um ok
any other questions I'd like to do
questions nowadays I'm I cut down on
buying opening books really you had the
dragon um with a dragon I always feel if
you play that you have some it's a bit
very difficult if you if your memory
fails you were also difficult in the
night of course but I don't know I draw
them I'd rather play them play the night
off yeah um time hon office is what I
want to want to play the system this is
easier there's a question how do i like
the tea gosh pong serious the tea gosh
pong serious is something in german it's
a serious power to use of off books i
recommend a lot
how do i like the caro-kann book by you
monkey whose car is a very good book do
I own any luck to all our books and not
anymore I had had one or two of his
opening books i think but i saw with
them they are not that terrible I mean
the london system book was pretty ok
what's the most positional sicilian on
blacks from becks point of view either
the tomorrow when town variations
probably that makes makes quite some
sense ok guys I have to finish the
stream we are already on overtime 15
minutes plus I'm i will be on next week
um when we are all ready yet during the
sink world cup um I as you still dash
out questions yeah sorry we have to do
that have to do that next time ok guys
thanks for watching I'll be online next
week Mondays same time where's that
button actually here it is